we're getting new details about the nhp
trooper critically injured during a
chase on the i-15 yesterday
he's been identified as trooper micah
may a 46-year-old husband and father of
two he was flown to umc
hospital yesterday and that's where we
find hector mejia reporting live
with the latest hector hey there bianca
well the latest update from this morning
is that trooper micah may remains in
critical condition here at university
medical center where we've seen
a huge outpouring of support trooper may
joined the nevada department of public
safety back in 2008
he is 46 years old and the nevada
highway patrol
shared a picture of him his family by
his side and thankful
for all of the support for almost 24
hours now
nhp and other law enforcement agencies
keeping watch outside
trooper may was hurt yesterday he was
deploying spike strips on i-15 near
sahara trying to stop a pursuit with a
carjacking suspect
when that driver hit him and kept on
going according to police
the dramatic end was caught on video may
went through the windshield
the suspect was eventually shot and
killed by troopers
may was airlifted here to umc now the
injured police officers fund has
established a link for anyone
wanting to help his family you can go to
ipof
dot vegas now as for the suspect today
we learned the pursuit also went through
surface
surface streets in north las vegas we
called the clark county coroner's office
to see if they were able to release the
name of the suspect yet but they told us
they are not ready to release that
information yet reporting live outside
umc hector mejia
8 news now